all the good folks all the people who
you know were meant to be in the
military there wasn't a lot of them left
and I know that during my basic training
in uh AIT which is like Advanced
Training for your job um we had
people the the treatment of peoples and
their standards was unbelievable uh
women were you know like we had some
people in there that were like 5 foot2
couldn't carry the load for themselves
we would go on Ruck marches that were
really 12 mil long and they would end up
falling out and they would get put in a
truck and get driven back and or they
couldn't shoot what you were supposed to
shoot what the standard was and they
would pass them anyway why would they
pass anyway because they have to fill
these spots creating cannon fodder
basically this is the other thing that's
happening is that recruitment all of the
numbers are actually off from what I
know from people who are inlisted right
now is that they are using like they are
you shifting data to pad their numbers
because they are so far behind in in
recruitment goals I mean it's not good
but once you get into the army they need
to keep you there